do you ever wish to know that there was
some you know a small private ldml group
where you can just not like when you go
to board meetings or when you listen to
coaches telling their you know players
on the field you know they use all kind
of worse so because whatever you say
because public and people pick it up and
they don't know the context honestly now
I mean we have private mailing lists for
security issues we have private mailing
lists sometimes for actually quite often
it's not mailing lists it's just when
you have some issue come up and you just
email a group of people because it's
maybe not sensitive but it's something
that also you want to talk about I mean
usually it's not code usually it's about
maintainer shape issues things like that
so we do have private email but almost
always when when that happens I find to
be problematic because then you don't
end up having archives of it you end up
having to bring new people in and they
are missing all the context so I'm much
happier just having all the discussion
in the open and it doesn't always work
that way and it does mean and then when
when people get heated that's in they
open too but I think that health that's
healthier than trying to kind of say it
doesn't exist how does it affect you
personally then you get old mad and
angry and you know and you're still in
your bathrobe
I actually so what happens to me is
sometimes I get really it's and is of
the reason I get upset is almost always
the same is somebody's not acknowledging
the bug that they introduced I'm trying
to say hey we we don't need to I fixed
the problem
I never mind the fact that somebody's
not complaining about the fact that I
also introduced a problem but I
occasionally explode
and then I fire off an email and then I
forget about I mean I don't I don't tend
to stay upset all that long I have
noticed that because there are like news
people that follow my email and then
write a story about the the exploding
ones that are fully rare in the end I
have actively stopped responding
sometimes it needs to be something I
really care about so I've I never
respond a lot to email I just get too
much of it but in the last few years
I've just decided yeah it's just less
pain - not even respond at all sometimes
so it has resulted in me going quiet
sometimes but it's it's not a huge issue
respond to the press queries about it no
I'm usually like talking to journalists
responding to flame wars over exhibit on
on the main list I'm like I want to
respond and then I decide now let's just
press Delete instead right it's not
worth where's the pain but it's actually
fairly rare I mean I explode maybe once
a year couple of times a year
and Wilson just justified mostly you
know well I think so people have to see
the context they don't know that's
that's one of the issues is even if even
if it were justified it's quite often
that people don't see see the context
exactly
and then obviously the normal day-to-day
stuff that doesn't generate flame wars
also does not generate news so I mean
that's but that's that's understandable
that's a that's not that's how that's
how everything works
it's not about open source I mean this
is how no politics in the yes
you